STAND BY WE’LL BE DOWN THERE
SHORTLY.
BRIAN:  ONE OF THE BIG DEBATES
OVER INLAND COUNTY IS ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS PUT AN END TO IT
ONE OF THE MANY THINGS HE’S DONE
TO STAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE AND
WHAT’S HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY
AND SOCIETY AND ESPECIALLY IN
FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR WELCOME BACK.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
HOW YOU ALL DOING?
STEVE: DOING OKAY IT’S A FRIDAY.
BRIAN:  YEAH, I MEAN, THAT ISSUE
WE’RE HANDLING INLAND, ALMOST ON
A DAILY BASIS, WHY DID YOU FEEL
AS THOUGH YOU HAD TO GET IN
FRONT OF IT?
WHAT REALLY MADE YOU THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING I’VE GOT TO
STOP BEFORE IT GETS ROOTS.
>> WELL, YOU WERE SEEING IT
SPROUT UP ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
AND YOU WERE SEEING IT SPROUT UP
IN SOME OF THESE WOKE
CORPORATIONS AS WELL, AND, YOU
KNOW, WE FELT VERY STRONGLY THAT
OUR TAX DOLLARS SHOULD NOT BE
GOING TO TEACHING THESE THEORIES
THAT ARE NOT BASED IN FACT, AND
THAT REALLY DIVIDE PEOPLE AND IS
EFFECTIVELY A STORM OF STATE
SANCTIONED RACISM SO WE HAD HUGE
SUPPORT IN DOING THAT.
PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE,
AND I THINK YOU’RE SEEING THAT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND SO I
KNOW THAT THERE’S STILL SOME
PEOPLE ON THE FAR LEFT WHO ARE
TRYING TO JUSTIFY THIS , BUT I
THINK YOU’RE SEEING AMERICANS
REALLY COME TOGETHER AND SAY WE
DO NOT WANT THIS IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AINSLEY: GOVERNOR I KNOW YOU’RE
SENDING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PATROL THE BORDER BECAUSE THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
PRESIDENT HAVEN’T GONE DOWN
THERE SO STATES ARE HAVING TO
ACT ALONE, AND YOU’RE SO, IT’S
VERY KIND OF YOU TO HELP.
YOU’RE NOT THE ONLY STATE BUT TO
HELP THOSE FOLKS OUR BORDER
PATROL AGENTS WHO NEED ALL OF
THE HELP THEY CAN GET.
RALPH NORMAN IS A REPUBLICAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA A
CONGRESSMAN, AND HE WAS GRILLING
THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, THE HOUSE
HOMELAND SECURITY MEETING
YESTERDAY MORNING AND HE WAS
TESTIFYING AND HE WAS ASKING HIM
, WHY ISN’T THE VICE
PRESIDENT GOING DOWN THERE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU MADE THE STATEMENT AND
MY QUESTION WAS UNFAIR.
I’M MAKING THE STATEMENT THAT
YOUR COMMENTS ARE JUST WORDS AND
THEY’RE VERY UNFAIR.
I ASKED YOU A SIMPLE QUESTION
AND I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO JUST
ANSWER SIMPLY.
DOES IT MAKE SENSE FOR THE
LEADERS OF THE FREE
WORLD TO GO AND TO TALK TO AND
SEE WHAT’S GOING ON AT THE
BORDER.
>> I AM THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND IT IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MANAGE THE
BORDER AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND I HAVE VISITED THE
BORDER ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
THE VICE PRESIDENT SERVED AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
BORDER STATE, OF CALIFORNIA,
AND SHE IS QUITE FAMILIAR WITH
THE SITUATION ON THE BORDER.
AINSLEY: SO YOUR OFFICER,
GOVERNOR, ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
BORDER BEFORE THE VICE PRESIDENT
, WHO IS BASICALLY THE
BORDER CZAR.
>> WELL, THE SAD THING ABOUT
THIS IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS JUST COMPLETELY ADVOCATED ITS
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE HAD POLICIES UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP THAT WERE WORKING.
THE BORDER WAS UNDER CONTROL,
AND BIDEN COMES IN AND THEY
KNOWINGLY REVOKED ALL OF THESE
POLICIES, KNOWING WHAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN AND NOW THEY ARE JUST
SHOWING A CALLUS DISREGARD AND
NOT JUST US BORDER COMMUNITIES
BEING AFFECTED.
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE’RE DEALING
WITHIN PLACES PARTICULARLY SOME
OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES IS THE
MESS AND IT’S ALL COMING
FROM ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE CARTELS ARE ABSOLUTELY
EATING BIDEN AND HARRIS’ LUNCH,
AND THE FACT THAT SHE WON’T EVEN
GO DOWN THERE, BUT LOOK, WHAT
GREG ABBOTT’S DOING, THEY’RE
STEPPING UP AND FILLING A VOID
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
LEFT ITS LACK OF LEADERSHIP SO
WHEN THEY ASK FOR SUPPORT I FELT
IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO,
THAT FLORIDA BE THERE TO HELP
THEM OUT.
THEY’VE HELPED US OUT IN THE
PAST WHEN WE’VE HAD
EMERGENCIES AND NATURAL DISASTER
S BUT THE IDEA THAT
WE’RE EVEN HAVING TO DO THIS IS
REALLY A SAD COMMENTARY ON THE
LEFT OF FEDERAL LEADERSHIP.
STEVE: AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE GREAT STATE OF FLORIDA
SUPPORTS YOU IN THIS MOVE, AND
SHE POINTED OUT YESTERDAY, 21
FLORIDIANS DIE EVERY DAY,
BECAUSE OF OPIOIDS AND THAT’S
WHY IT’S A CRISIS AND WE NEED TO
STOP THEM FROM COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
GOVERNOR, YOU’VE BEEN IN
WASHINGTON.
YOU’RE THERE IN FLORIDA AND
TALLAHASSEE.
EXPLAIN THE POLITICS, IF YOU
WOULD.
THIS HAS BEEN YOUR BUSINESS FOR
A WHILE.
EXPLAIN THE POLITICS ON HOW
SOMEBODY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO
PUT HER IN CHARGE OF THIS AND
NOT HAVE HER GO AND SEE IT WITH
HER OWN TWO EYES.
>> I THINK THAT THEY REALIZE
IT’S A DISASTER AND I THINK THEY
THINK IF SHE GOES IT’S JUST
GOING TO HIGHLIGHT IT EVEN MORE,
BUT I’LL TELL YOU, NOT SHOWING
UP, NOT TAKING DECISIVE ACTION
IS ULTIMATELY, IT’S THE BAD
POLICY RESPONSE, ULTIMATELY
POLITICALLY IT’S NOT GOING TO
WORK.
PEOPLE ARE FED UP WITH THIS.
THEY WANT TO SEE ACTION.
THIS IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S
RESPONSIBILITY AND YOU HAVE ALL
OF US AND THE STATES NOW HAVING
TO STEP UP AND DO THEIR JOB FOR
THEM.
BRIAN:  JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
WHEN YOU WERE IN CONGRESS, THEN
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS WENT TO
HOMESTEAD TO POINT OUT THERE
WERE KIDS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER BEING PLACED INTO
FACILITIES LIKE THIS AND SHE WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR CONDITION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT CONCERN?
>> IT’S AMAZING HOW THINGS SEEM
TO CHANGE BASED ON WHERE THEY’RE
SITTING, BUT OF COURSE, THEY
WERE JUST USING THAT TO TRY TO
ATTACK DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WAS THE ONLY REASON THEY
WERE DOING IT.
THAT’S WHY THEY HAVE DONE THESE
POLICIES BECAUSE THEY THINK
TRUMP IS BAD.
IF HE DID IT, IT MUST BE BAD.
THEY HAVE TO DO THE OPPOSITE.
THAT’S NOT GOOD LEADERSHIP.
GOOD LEADERSHIP IS DOING WHAT’S
BEST FOR THE COUNTRY AND
OBVIOUSLY SHE IS FAILING IN THAT
REGARD AND SO IS THE PRESIDENT.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOU JUST
RECENTLY SIGNED A BILL TO GIVE
POLICE DOGS PRIORITY MEDICAL
HELP.
TELL US MORE ABOUT THIS.
>> WELL WE’RE ACTUALLY, YOU
GUYS ARE GETTING THE PREVIEW,
BECAUSE I’M GOING TO TRANSITION
OUT OF THIS INTERVIEW DUE TO
PRESS CONFERENCE WE’RE HERE AT
THE ST. JOHN’S COUNTY SHERIFF’S
OFFICE SIGNING THE BILL PROBABLY
IN THE NEXT 30 MINUTES, AND WHAT
IT DOES IS WE HAVE THESE CANINES
THAT ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
PROTECTING US, THEY PERFORM A
VALUABLE FUNCTION, AND YET UNDER
FLORIDA LAW, IF THEY ARE INJURED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY THEY COULD
NOT BE TRANSPORTED BY EMT
PERSONNEL LIKE AN OFFICER
BE ABLE TO, AND THIS BILL CHANGE
S THAT.
THIS GIVES THEM THAT EMERGENCY,
THOSE EMERGENCY SERVICES, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
TRANSPORTED, AND HOPEFULLY, THAT
WILL BE ENOUGH TO POTENTIALLY
SAVE SOME OF THE CANINES LIVES
BECAUSE YOU’LL HAVE SOME OF
THESE ASSAILANTS TRY TO SHOOT
THE DOGS AND THEY WILL DO A LOT
OF REALLY BAD THINGS SO WE
REALLY, I THINK, LEANED IN AND
WE ALSO IN FLORIDA HAVE A NUMBER
OF GREAT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN TRAINING DOGS, WE
HAVE ORGANIZATIONS THAT TRAIN
DOGS FOR SERVICE MEMBERS, SUFFER
ING FROM PTSD, AND A WHOLE
HOST OF THINGS SO WE’RE REALLY
PROUD OF WHAT FLORIDA DOES TO
STAND BY OUR FOUR LEGGED FRIENDS
STEVE: AND YOU’RE GOING TO BE
SIGNING THAT BILL VERY SHORTLY.
GOVERNOR, LET’S CHANGE FROM A
NEWS CHANNEL TO THE GOLF CHANNEL
AINSLEY: [LAUGHTER]
STEVE: YESTERDAY, YOU ACTUALLY
POSTED YOUR THREE-YEAR-OLD SON
MASON, AND PEOPLE LOVE TO GOLF
IN FLORIDA BUT USUALLY THEY
START WHEN THEY’RE LIKE 30 OR
40.
HE’S THREE, AND HE CAN REALLY
DRIVE THAT BALL.
WHAT DID YOU POST AS THE CAPTION
UNDER MASON’S PICTURE THERE?
>> WELL, I SAID THE GUY IS
THREE YEARS OLD AND HE’S ALREADY
GOT A BETTER SWING THAN HIS OLD
MAN DOES, AND I WORK AT IT WHEN
I CAN.
I HAVE A BASEBALL BACKGROUND SO
I USED TO SWING BUT HE’S JUST,
MY DAUGHTER, MADISON, IS REALLY
GOOD TOO.
THEY JUST HAVE GREAT HAND-EYE
COORDINATION, BUT HE IS OBSESSED
WITH HITTING GOLF BALLS AND
BASEBALLS.
HE DOES IT ALL DAY LONG AND I
THINK YOU SEE IN THAT.
HE’S HITTING LIKE A NINE IRON,
HE’S HITTING THAT 60-YARDS, AS A
THREE-YEAR-OLD KID AND HE’S GOT
NICE STRAIGHT, MAYBE A LITTLE
BIT OF A FADE, AND SO I THINK
HE’S GOT A GREAT FUTURE IF
THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS TO DO.
BRIAN:  YOU KNOW WHAT’S AMAZING
IS HE HAS NO RITUALS.
THE BALL GOES DOWN HE JUST HITS
IT.
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS GETTING SET
BUT IT’S NO SURPRISE, REALLY,
BECAUSE YOU MET YOUR WIFE ON THE
DRIVING RANGE, DIDN’T YOU?
AND ISN’T CASEY A REALLY GOOD
GOLFER?
>> SHE IS.
SHE’S A GREAT ATHLETE.
SHE WAS A COLLEGE EQUESTRIAN
SCHOLARSHIP, AND WE WERE JUST
HAPPENED TO BE AT THE DRIVING
RANGE NEXT TO EACH OTHER, WHERE
IS MASON, COME HERE, BUDDY.
SHE’S WACKING BALLS, I’VE GOT
HIM RIGHT HERE, AND SO YEAH.
SHOW HIM HOW YOU HIT THE BALL.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> A LITTLE BIT EARLY FOR HIM
BUT YEAH SO WE DID THAT AND IT’S
SOMETHING WE’VE ENJOYED TOGETHER
AND THESE KIDS, I THINK, REALLY
ARE FORTUNATE THEY’VE GOT A
MOTHER WHOSE VERY GOOD LOOKING
AND VERY ATHLETIC AND SO I THINK
THEY ARE GETTING EVERYTHING FROM
HER SIDE.
STEVE: THERE IS YOUR WHOLE
FAMILY RIGHT THERE IT’S GOOD YOU
CAN WRITE-OFF THIS APPEARANCE.
>> MADISON WAVE TO THE CAMERA.
BRIAN:  NOW MADISON, WHEN I HAD
A CHANCE TO SPEND THE DAY WITH
YOU, GOVERNOR ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT’S HAPPENING YOUR
KIDS ARE RUNNING AROUND THE
HOUSE IN CONTROL, HAVING FUN
BUT YOU WERE ABLE TO SHOW ME
MADISON’S SWING, TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS SWING.
YOU MISSED THE FIRST ONE BUT SHE
HIT LIKE FIVE IN A ROW.
YOU’RE MAKING THE MOST OF THE
GOVERNOR’S MANSION.
SO THIS IS AN ATHLETIC FAMILY.
>> WE’VE GOT AN ABILITY TO DO
ALL KIND OF ATHLETICS ALL AROUND
THE MANSION COMPOUND AND THESE
KIDS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT, BUT
THAT’S KIND OF, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TO LEARN WHEN WE’RE DEALING
WITH THE YOUNG KIDS, THEY MAY
PUT FINGER PAINT ON THE
WALLPAPER IN THE STATE
DINING ROOM WE’VE GOT TO
TROUBLESHOOT THEY MAY DO THIS OR
DO THAT SO IT’S A CONSTANT
EFFORT TO KEEP ONE STEP AHEAD OF
THEM.
AINSLEY: THERE WAS ONE ON TOP OF
THE SIDE BOARD IN THE DINING
ROOM.
WHICH ONE WAS THAT?
>> ACTUALLY, WE ENDED UP
GETTING BOTH, WHEN YOU ALL CAME,
WHEN BRIAN CAME, BUT THE REASON
THAT IT HAPPENED, THE LAST TIME
THERE WAS A BABY IN THE MANSION
WAS OVER 50 YEARS AGO AND THEY
TOOK A PICTURE OF THE GOVERNOR’S
THEN BABY SON IN THERE, SO WHEN
WE CAME IN, WE PUT MASON IN AND
GOT HIM TO DO A PICTURE, AND
THEN THEY BOTH JUMPED IN WHEN
BRIAN WAS DOWN A FEW MONTHS AGO.
BRIAN:  SO GOVERNOR, YOU’RE
GOING TO HAVE A HARD TIME, YOU
WORK A LOT NOW AND PEOPLE ARE
HELPING YOU WHEN THEY START
HAVING GAMES AND AFTER SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
A HARD TIME RUNNING PRESS
CONFERENCES KNOWING THEY ARE
PLAYING BASEBALL, GOLF, SOCCER,
FOOTBALL, WHATEVER.
>> OH, NO, NO, NO, WE WILL NOT
BE SCHEDULING PRESS CONFERENCES
DURING ANY OF THEIR GAMES I’LL
MAKE SURE THAT I’M AT THE GAMES
WE’LL FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE
THAT WORK.
STEVE: YOU’LL BE THE ONLY PARENT
WITH A POLICE ESCORT TO LITTLE
LEAGUE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
EARLIER, WE’VE ACTUALLY
BECAUSE YOUR SON, MASON, WHO
OBVIOUSLY GETS HIS ATHLETIC PROW
ESS FROM YOUR WIFE,
IS SO GOOD AT GOLF WE’VE PUT
TOGETHER A SIDE BY SIDE
COMPARISON OF MASON AT THREE
WITH A VERY YOUNG TIGER WOODS.
TIGER WOODS WHEN HE WAS A LITTLE
BOY, SHOWED UP ON I BELIEVE THE
MIKE DOUGLAS SHOW, AND --
AINSLEY: LOOK AT THAT.
BRIAN:  WOW.
STEVE: STUNNING THE SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN YOUR CHILD AND TIGER
WOODS, WHO LIVES IN JUPITER,
FLORIDA.
BRIAN:  DO YOU HAVE A MONITOR
THERE, GOVERNOR?
>> NO BUT THEY DID SHOW IT TO
ME BEFORE I GOT ON AND SO, YOU
KNOW, IT’S PRETTY NEAT TO SEE.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANYONE
THAT’S BEEN A BETTER GOLF
PRODIGY THAN TIGER.
HE’S A VERY SPECIAL GUY BUT YOU
NEVER KNOW.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY START, I
THINK GOLF, IF YOU START YOUNG,
IT REALLY DOES HELP, BECAUSE IT
BUILDS THE MUSCLE MEMORY.
I DIDN’T START PLAYING UNTIL I
WAS IN MY MID-20S AFTER MY
BASEBALL CAREER WAS OVER AND I
HAD THE HAND-EYE COORDINATION
BUT IT IS A DIFFERENT SWING.
HE’S VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
GETTING THAT CLUB FACE ON THE
BALL AND GIVING IT A RIDE SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
HE CAN DO IN THE FUTURE.
BRIAN:  HE’S COMFORTABLE BEING
ON TELEVISION.
TOTALLY NATURAL.
AINSLEY: GOVERNOR, WE WANTED TO
PUT BRIAN DID PLAY SOME GOLF
WITH PRESIDENT BUSH AND WE
WANTED TO COMPARE HIS SWING TO
MASONS.
BRIAN:  OH, YOU’RE DEAD.
YOU DID NOT WANT TO COMPARE MY
SWING.
AINSLEY: [LAUGHTER]
IT’S NOT BAD.
BRIAN:  I AM SO STIFF.
AINSLEY: I THINK MASON MIGHT BE
BETTER.
>> THEY SHOWED THAT BEFORE TOO.
BRIAN, I THINK YOU GOT GOOD
TECHNIQUE.
I MEAN, I WOULD DOG YOU IF YOU
DIDN’T.
I THINK IT WAS A GOOD SWING.
BRIAN:  VERY POSITIVE.
YOU THINK MIGHT BE POTENTIAL.
AINSLEY: I THINK IT ALL WORKED
OUT WELL FOR YOU.
YOU’RE DOING OKAY.
BRIAN:  GOVERNOR THANKS FOR THE
KIND WORDS SO WE GOT TO
TALK ABOUT POLITICS WE TALKED
ABOUT DOGS, AND WE TALKED ABOUT
HIS LIFE.
STEVE: CAN WE HAVE MASON JUST
WAVE GOODBYE, IF THE GOVERNOR IS
STILL THERE?
>> WAVE GOODBYE TO THE CAMERA.
AINSLEY: GOODBYE, MASON.